let's let's give this a go now I've got
my components here and like I said it's
most people's brains tend to find
addition a lot easier than subtraction
it also avoids the fact that like wait
which shot am i doing again do I go up
do I go down and then you get confusing
sorry so that's why what I choose to do
is if I've got let's say I recommend any
time you see a subtraction that you
actually reframe it as an addition it's
really quite easy to do to go from this
to flip it upside down and then all the
work you have to do all the mental work
of like well how's it behaving it you're
still in addition mode okay
so we can take all the lessons we just
let over there and give the crap here
and the first thing you're going to do
is I want to think about domain okay so
I've got some domain problems the same
time a problems I had of it there
where can I exist what is the domain of
my composite function left of the y-axis
or I can go right that's all good and
you're actually going to get as you -
you're going to get your vertical
asymptote there now what starts to
happen when you go horizontal is again
you can think hold on look over here on
the right hand side you see on my arm I
connect what I'm adding to that graph is
an increasingly small amount right a
very very small quantity so whenever you
see this kind of behavior that means
you're going to be approaching something
else in the same asymptotic way okay but
the difference is you remember over here
right what you are adding was a positive
graph you are any positive to positive
okay so that's why you ended up higher
but here I'm having a positive to a
negative right so when I add this guy on
I don't go higher I go just a little bit
slower does that make sense if I'm
adding a negative
vitia okay now therefore I'm going to be
approaching this y equals x asymptote
I'm going to at least on the right hand
side I'm going to be approached it from
beneath okay that's the first thing
under secondly this is again a very
different I'm here in the last time we
didn't find any intercepts we never
collided with what with either actors
okay but this time we do now you've got
two ways of working this out number one
like I said if you graph this visually
quite accurately the place where I'm
going to intersect with the axis is
where this positive and this negative
are exactly equal to each other
and they will cancel each other out does
that make sense like if this is exactly
higher it cause want to know how this is
lower then when I add them together and
just come back to the axis okay
so looking at where I've grabbed mine it
looks something like of that point there
you see that distance is roughly
equivalent okay so you can literally get
a ruler out I wouldn't get a room back
if I had one right now actually it's
just long enough
okay and I would say okay look where is
that point where is that point where I'm
actually going to be about equal right
now as it happens because we chose it
very very well I've chosen very very
easy graphs here you actually know
exactly what that point units are right
it's going to be x equals one one up
here and x equals one negative one down
here so therefore we're going to be
passing through the answers right there
and I can make the same argument back
over here and x equals negative one
again you can compare that just as that
this should be roughly the city now I
already know I'm gonna approaching this
asymptote from beneath okay what's
happening over here can you describe him
okay it's going to be approaching this
guy down here why is it appreciating
this one it's because the graph up here
is getting close to zero
okay does that make sense so therefore
I'm gonna be starting it closer to this
guy and I'll be just above you see we
just [ __ ] up adding a small positive
value okay
so therefore approaching this room from
beneath oppression this one through a
bar looks to me like that okay do you
see how I do it yes okay now yesterday
so I am like what does it hasit turn me
and pass into it is a line that you're
approaching but at least to the
extremities you'll never crossing you
you actually never get there okay now we
know that that you know I need to wiggle
and like somewhere in the keep but offer
infinities or add zeros right I'm
getting closer but never getting there
so strictly speaking yeah why cuz minus
1 over X at that little region there is
an asset oh okay in the same way that y
equals sorry that x equals 0 is also an
asymptote in this little region here
okay however what will ask you to know
it means if I massive Twitter based upon
superior ah if I have taught it to y
equals negative 1 over X here do you see
like because this guy is also asymptotic
to x equals 0 then my result here is
getting squeezed between these two right
you see he's getting crushed in that
little spot it's gonna get closer and
closer to 0 so being that minus 1 over X
is approaching 0 okay but never gets
this guy is also approaching 0 he
doesn't have a choice right in fact
there's a you laugh at this we're going
to get to it when we do the calculus of
trigonometric functions but this of this
behavior actually has a lot it's cold I
kid you not the squeeze law like because
I'm a bad graph I'll graph the black one
that I'm interested in is getting
squeezed between these two things
he can't do anything else he has their
choice of where to go okay so therefore
I don't need to put in minus whatever X
as an acetone because x equals zero is
sufficient can I say that this one is a
personality yeah uh yes again that's
kind of how I made the argument that
look this guy's approaching zero what
I'm adding to this graph is approaching
zero so therefore I've been purging that
graph um if you you to imagine here
right um if it's appreciate x equals
zero then it should also be approaching
that graph it's just we haven't drawn
enough of it to demonstrate that because
remember this riffraff that he is also
doing the same thing they are not just
going in just as slightly two rates okay
I'll get to that in a second how about
we finish the graph okay now now you can
see what kind of symmetry do I have just
like before I'm adding an odd function
right through another odd function right
so what you get together is another one
function so therefore one brings the
same behavior just in Reverse
photography yeah the question was can we
use these techniques to graphs of the
others if I got given this in an
extension one exam would this be an okay
way to go okay now the short answer is
no okay and I will tell you I'll tell
you why and why that's not really a
problem okay
the short answer is is you got given
this an extension one example okay
you're being expected number one to be
able to tell me like okay you two where
this is you tell me where that is by the
way another analytical way that you'd be
able to work out that for instance how
do I know y equals x is an oblique
acetone well have a look over here
just have a look back at the original
function right if I take the limit as X
approaches positive infinity
what's happening to this guy heads up he
just disappears right he vanishes away
and his thought is trivial right so I
know it from like two unit three two
concepts that this is going to disappear
therefore all I end up with is this okay
now you're also going to be expected to
find stationary points now addition and
subtraction coordinates it's a it's a
visual way of doing it it's not a look
that's exactly where it it's I have to
differentiate to show that okay and
that's what you're expected to do in an
extension one exam um you could have
graphed this without this technique that
I've just shown show you okay however
extension two students are going to
encounter graphs that cannot be done in
any other way apart from this now like I
said even though this doesn't end up
being a technique you can use that
understand that we're talking about like
look at how its behaving tell me what's
going on down there all of those skills
are really important to you when you are
graphing all of the other things you
will encounter all the other rational
functions that you know about I'm gonna
show you I was having at the time I'm
some examples where it's like oh this is
such an obvious way of thinking about
why don't they learn this in extension
world it's like um time basically like
it does actually make sense for
extension wants to Suze to learn you can
wrap your head around it it's just
enough time to go through I would
encourage I would encourage that like
I'll show you in a second and it should
really be going on up here right it
should be thinking about okay wait does
this match with what I expected to do if
I'm adding the ordinance it's just kind
of another extra tool for you to analyze
yeah I know I've got the exact right
thing because I can see it